Film Courage: What does an outline look like?
Mark Sanderson, screenwriter and author: Well
for me on these assignments that I do they
are usually 10 or 12 pages.
It’s the entire story, treatment and it’s
not just line by line.
I mean there are some outlines that it’s
just a line literally.
But for television they’re 8 acts so everything
has to be broken down but I write it as a
story so if you were to sit down and read
it, you’d be reading the story of the movie
which I think is essential to create, in fact
I’ve had friends that do this “Oh, I’m
just going to sit down and I have the vague
idea and I’m just going to write.”
And I’m like “You’ll be lost in the
barren wasteland of Act 2.
With no water, you’ll be in the desert lost
and you’ll wonder how you’re going to
trudge through the 75-pages or whatever.
I’m a huge advocate of starting outlines
before starting writing and I know it’s
probably 50, 60, 70 percent of the work because
it makes the load a lot easier and you can
write a faster screenplay if you have an outline.
Now that doesn’t say there is no room for
changes or improvising but if you don’t
have a solid roadmap going in…it’s almost
like a pre-draft of a first draft.
And I’m not an advocate of what people say
the vomit draft or just spill it out.
But I don’t have the luxury of spilling
it out on my assignment jobs, I don’t.
I really have to turn in let’s say on a
ten scale turn in probably an eight…an eight
out of ten…because I’m now holding up
development and I’ve also done rewrites
on other screenwriter’s work/projects that
means that the script that they had went through
multiple drafts and still is not there.
And they have a buyer, they have network who
is waiting on the script and so I’ve also
been hired to do rewrite job where I can come
in but it’s like a page one rewrite where
see the script that you have you can’t use
any of it, the names yes, the concept yes
but you basically…but that’s something
that I’ve learned how to do which is good
because there is a lot of rewrite work out
there and some writers look down on it.
An example is that I took a rewrite job and
that ended up being three more jobs for the
same company because that opened the door
for them and they were thankful for that.
But you never know what opportunity you’re
going to either turn down or accept.
But back to your point about the outline,
I think it’s extremely important to do an
outline before your screenplay because it’s
easier to work out the problems there than
it is writing a complete first draft and just
having so many problems.
And also it trains you like I said, like you’re
an olympic athlete, it trains you for the
time that you do have to do outlines because
I’m not allowed to write these assignments
without an outline that I have to create.
So they just wont let me go to pages.
They have other people involved who have to
okay it.
So the outline is extremely important.
Film Courage: In your book do you have any
examples of an actual outline?
I know sometimes viewers will ask “Where
do I find a copy of an outline?”
Mark Sanderson: I don’t.
I’m sure you can find it online.
But it’s not that mysterious.
There is a step outline, there’s a one sheet
which is just a one sheet of paper which is
the concept.
It’s sort of a short synopsis.
There’s the log line which is even smaller
(two or three sentences).
So there are different steps and you have
to have each along the way because you have
the quick pitch “Hmmm…I’m not interested.”
Then you have the quick pitch and they go
“Hmmm?
I’m willing to read something (not the script
but I’ll ready the synopsis).
Then there are different steps as to how interested
they are to read what you want as the final
product, the final script is for them to read.
A step outline, I’ve done outlines that
were 30 pages.
I mean you triple it and you have the script.
Everything had to be worked out because it
was very technical the way the film was going
to be shot from like an iPhone and from different
things and so really it had to be spelled
out because on the set you just can’t leave
it up to chance so.
But after that point I could have written
a script in weeks because it was all figured
out, I’d figured it out already.
And you want that outline for those dark periods
when you’re stuck.
You don’t want to be stuck trying to figure
out plot points when you should be filling
pages.
That’s the worst part, that’s the worst
place to be.
Film Courage: How long does it usually take
you to write an outline?
Mark Sanderson: From once the concept is there,
like two weeks, working everyday.
And then that usually ends up being 12-15
pages as the outline in my experience with
my producers.
And that outline is then rewritten sometimes
two or three times, I get notes on the outline
before I’m allowed to go to the script.
So the script is the final…once we okay
the outline, then go to pages.
And that’s not to say they don’t change
their mind once the script is finished because
that’s the crazy part…
“Yeah but you agreed to it in the outline?”
But we built the house but now we don’t
kind of like the way it looks.
You know we thought we did.
So that happens, too.
To be open and prepared for rewrites at all
stages it does allow you to write a faster
first draft is to have a solid outline.
Because for me I have to see the film in my
head before I can write it.
And I know that I have a lot of problems ahead
of me if I can’t see it.
I don’t lock in, like I’ve almost seen
the movie.
Like when you watch a movie, you remember
it.
I have to see it that way.
And I know things are working.
And you know the outline is good for living
with your characters.
You get to live with them.
You get to see how the movie is working or
doesn’t work before you sit down and write
that screenplay, which is building the house
(which is almost at the pre-blueprint) in
my opinion, that’s been my experience.
But I know writers who just want to write
down a couple of lines and wing it.
There are so many things that can go wrong
and why not turn in the most amazing first
draft you can?
I don’t see the problem with that.
And like I say, you have to when you’re
doing assignment work.
You want fewer drafts.
You don’t want eight drafts because nothing
is working.
You want to turn that in where they go “Wow!”
One of my assignments I did two drafts and
two polishes.
We’re done!
That’s what they like.
They don’t 5 [drafts] “You’re not getting
it…”
That’s where you get fired and they hire
someone else who can facilitate the notes
and get it moving.
It’s creative but it’s also a business
at the time, unfortunately.